hey
everyone um I really wanted a flashing
presentation and I got
it we'll communicate in more
through yeah my name is May I'm a
machine learning engineer at un G it's a
reinsurance company which means
insurance for insurance um and today
I'll talk about the business um how Els
are used and how I'm implementing it and
some challenges and how I'm solving that
throughout this presentation as the
screen flickers just feel free to close
your eyes and take a deep breath it'll
be a meditative experience it's going to
be
okay um so what is insurance insurance
is really protecting you from risk uh
it's like the umbrella and reinsurance
is like the meta umbrella on top of this
umbrella and your next question is going
like what it maybe like Meta Meta
umbrella yeah yeah that that does happen
yeah it's like all risks spreading in a
circle
basically essentially we make sure not
one player goes down if some some bad
things happen like earthquake for in
this case I work for life life insurance
so if you know one part of the world um
you know gets hit it the risks are
spread
up okay so what is the problem solving
um LMS are good at the big picture and I
find is really good at the small things
as well um and I figur I discovered this
Fring point in in our ETL system um
where each insurance company has their
own form so this is not real forms so
like all the fors are online anyways so
uh I'm not going to say like specific
companies um for privacy sake um but
each if you go and apply for insurance
every company will have their own and
these are typically not written anymore
so it's not like an OCR you know
application it's usually online
um like each company will ask for like
almost the same information but in
different wording so I'll give you an
example what that
means one company might ask you did you
stop taking anxiety medication and you
might say yes or
no feel free to close your
eyes and follow my voice another company
might say have you stopped taking
medication stopped taking medication for
anxiety
and the answer might be yes or no but
now you see these two questions are
asking the same thing but in different
wording so how so a person has to go in
and really uh correlate that there might
be a followup saying how long ago have
you stopped taking anxiety me and my
answer may be one year uh could be
integer float and another company might
might ask when did you stop taking it
now you put in put a year so now you got
to do some math here is 202 3 minus 2020
3 so now how do you correlate that again
a person has to go in and and do that it
might be a followup as well saying why
and that question doesn't even have a
context in it so you might say doctor
advis when I be free free um free text
there so as you can see there's of just
you know different questions can be
asked um same things asked by different
questions okay so how is this being
solved right now and writer goes in and
kind of correlates you know Maps the
questions as we as we say
it and my role is to replace his
underwriter which you know this process
in order to take this you know set of
questions into our thousand question um
knowledge base which then is used to
transform into features Fe into our
machine learning models um takes time it
usually takes about weeks or you know
sometimes months and our our average
onboarding is you know it's months
for a new client so the point is to
replace this underwriter with an LM
agent at least for some part of the
task okay so I'm going to go into this
red box here because this is what I'm
going to be focusing on for for this
talk I'll break that okay so let's open
up this red box and see what's
inside all
right so we have an applicant um let's
say this person person X okay we take
their questions and answers and we kind
of concatenate it we package into a into
a nice package and we pass it through
our first pass of disease classification
does this person have anxiety does this
person have depression does this person
have you know sleep apnea
Etc now after this presentation I hope
you don't have
anxiety okay the instruction would be
tell me whether the applicant has the
following disease answer yes no or can't
answer so this I'm passing this into
llama 2
7p um it's the chat
model and next so this is the whole
thing is the prompt here I'm going to
show you parts of it at a time so the
applicant info would be what your
applicant info is the question and
answer so I transformed that into Q
answer and then new line the new line is
important or like any some demarcation
that it's like a new new line new um new
set of information so question answer
question answer there might be 10 of
these there might be 50 of
these and then you have your questions
which are are disease
classifications so the questions I would
list it in in number format so this is
something that I figure out actually
works pretty well is the number format
so you can get it to answer multiple
questions in the same API
call
exciting okay and then so the questions
you get and you know as many as you want
with the token limit in
mind and then you have answer dot dot
and then you leave it like
that and the output looks something like
this the elm would say 1. yes 2 do no 3.
yes um and this you can then pass into a
Rex with a Rex pattern and turn into a
data
free okay
so with these now we have a decision so
if anxiety if number one the answer to
number one is
yes then we'll pass it into a disease
extraction prompt which means we'll get
more information if the person hits yes
for this um and you can do this for your
other like this is not Insurance
specific you can do it for any other
application it's like a chaining method
right chain Rex uh call Rex or any other
like Spacey or if you want to use
another um text extraction
platform so more extraction on how say
like how it's treated have they been in
the emergency room have they stopped
medication why these can be free form or
you can make them really really specific
as well so similarly for the other uh
questions you know a your depression if
it's yes we'll extract more information
the third one the fourth one if it's yes
then extract more
information and all of these would then
gets passed into DRX and gets cleaned up
and put in the Json nicely Json format
to then pass further along in this uh ml
pipeline okay so how do we know if we
can trust it so this is a big question
in the in the field right now is how do
you evaluate LM outputs so because we
had underwriter because that's what we
used to do uh we have gold like ground
labels essentially um so for each of
these step we know if a person has had
you know anxiety they have all these um
these conditions so we have a ground
truth label for each of these steps so
an evaluation function I have for each
of these steps then can
calculate a precision and recall number
for each of these so that's the number
in which uh I'm using to iterate on
whether a prompt is working whether you
know a format is
working and in general what I found was
it's really good at detecting
unanswerable questions so like let's say
if they don't don't even mention
anything about emergency rooms and we're
asking have you been to an emergency
room for for your sleep acum um the
modotto would very very consistently say
I cannot answer
that it's not as good at numbers so
extracting like how many years have you
been in the hospital or like you know
what it would sometimes confuse that
number with how many medications are you
taking so would say like two years but I
look at the you know the actual data
it's actually to medication um so the
number association with number is not as
great and one way I can think of is to
overcome this is you just extract like
the question or the answer in which the
number was in which hospitalization was
mentioned and then maybe do some more
manual task after that so that's not
that's something that needs to be worked
on um it but it's really great at yes or
no
questions so you can say have they been
hospitalized and yes or no that that's
pretty consist
consistent so if you have a very simple
task like you know a binary decision
that's I I would I would recommend this
uh this process okay so why is good you
can close your eyes now uh this is this
part I can you can just listen um Elms
are great at creative creative tasks
because they are trained on so much data
um there's you can get a variety of
outputs and you can also also
communicate with it to get you know what
you want um but in this case we're
focusing on you know the very small task
very very meal trivial task that you
know is repeatable when you are really
really
specific it's adaptable you can you can
adapt it to the format you want here I I
set the format one two three um I also
found that a one shot uh if you give it
like if you copy and paste exactly what
you want and put it like on top uh and
give it show it one example it would be
even better um keeping the to tokenid in
mind I found that you know just doing it
you know zero shot it was
fine uh you can integrate new data
source in this case is applicant data it
could be patient data um it could be you
know a customer data you can tell it uh
what you want and the reason why I
didn't go with the rag uh I know that's
probably one of the questions to come up
um because some questions don't really
have the context in it remember that
question said why yeah like why why what
uh what medication what medication for
for what condition some of those
questions aren't um don't have the
context embedded so I'll talk about this
in the next slide so because they don't
have context eded um my first approach
was well why don't we just reward the
question with uh with the context oh
actually that's the second so
uh
so H sorry one second yeah so the one
one alternative method I tried was was
well you can reward it so from this
question answer turn it into a statement
first so say did the application did the
applicant stopped taking meds and say
the applic the applicant has stopped
taking meds so use llm as a way to
reward like how a physician would you
know present a patient like 38-year-old
woman coming with back thinging blah
blah blah um to reward that into a
statement first so I tried that didn't
work as well at least not for llama 2
maybe uh because there were some
hallucinations uh it it it sometimes
would say oh the St the applicant
stopped taking medication in 2003 like
where did you get 2003 from this like
ridiculous um but you can I also told
told it to be uh only use the context
however that still I couldn't trust it
uh fully as much as the yes or no just a
very very straightforward
decision another way I tried was
question Association like how writer
actually used to it it is used to solve
the problem
currently um the question two question
answer might be like have you ever taken
medication before and are you currently
taking medication now if they took
medication before and not taking
medication now you can safely assume
that they stopped taking medication
right so that that does work but there
were other problems
like this one where the llm tries to
logic with you so I I try to step where
I you know after the answer I said
reasoning tell me why you uh you reason
this and it told me this question
Association P has the applicant ever
been hospitalized and the answer was yes
and it it said associated with has the
applicant ever lost work due to you know
this condition now a an underwriter
wouldn't be able to make this you know
you can't really make those two calls
logically what would you think you know
maybe so the LM told me because they
were hospitalized I think they lost work
but you can't really you can't really
make that assumption here because they
might be hospitalized on the weekend you
know you can't make that assumption
whereas the Lo the elm did make that
logical leap which you know it adds some
more ambiguity as more assumptions which
we didn't want to uh a risk we didn't
want to
take okay so here's a secret sauce uh
how to get a good response or at least
in my in my experience this structure
like with a three hashtags and the space
and instruction and follow by
instruction and followed by two new
lines this was this was pretty good uh
it it gave me very very consistent at
least more consistent than you know any
other um there you can also put like you
know system responses I've seen those as
well but this one is quite you know it's
clean and I just work for
me one thing that's surprising is take a
deep breath I told to take a deep breath
in the beginning of the instruction and
it worked really
well it was more consistent it was more
concise it tend to hallucinate
hallucinate less so we should all do
that right now take a deep
breath
okay if meditation works for an llm if
few meditation work for an
LM structuring with Rex so that's the
pattern I used to extract the you know
numbers and into into Data
frame be very specific with your
instructions and and questions be as
focused as you
can and lastly append the data that you
want to search on which in my case was
applicant data uh with some form of
demarcation like I tried the semicolon
method it was it worked well um as well
as well as the new
line all right so some challenges I I
encountered was
hallucination by adding more yeah the
model would add extra information into
the answer so counteract us with being
very specific yet again
prompt iteration how do I know if you
know a prompt work better than the
evaluation numbers with recall and um
Precision really really really helped so
now you have a number you can kind of
quantify which prompt is
better prompt generalization if I'm
using this on one client now if I want
to you know test it I will have to test
on um different clients and see if that
would generalize to different clients um
textual
representation test on variety now this
was the hardest one uh the null response
sometimes it would just won't say
anything uh and really don't have a
great answer for why it it just gets
stuck sometimes uh just just refuses
like okay you don't you're not working
today that's okay um but I just pass it
in again not pass all response in again
because of istic um generation you will
get like get likely to get another
response you pass it
again so that's all I have for El NL uh
be happy to take any
[Applause]
questions I work for
insurance insurance and we do the
question
okay so question is how do you extract
on unstructured data like transcript
maybe you know that's actually the
beauty of it is because of I'm taking
the structur data in a you know form and
I'm making it into kind of stuffing it
into an unstructured format so you can
can pass that in if you provide it there
is not like under 4,000 whole things
4,000 yeah we can pass the whole thing
in uh and you know maybe maybe first do
a summarization on that and then and
then pass the summary in yeah you
can um I can confirm that with
transcripts I've transcribed a lot of
core sense of conversations and
summarization with the kind of proper
structure you've been using works
extremely well for us but I did have a
followup question which was uh what
temperature settings were you using yeah
it was point one yeah I wanted to be
very very
um to the point and not you know not be
creative in this case it's not a
creative task just do a
job uh yes for your prompt iteration are
you using any tools to take keep the
history of your iterations
oress um well at first I wasn't I was
just kind of experimenting um but ml has
a great tool now we're putting that line
we we have a model loing tool
like so we filling that in
I yeah
back um I could probably use some
depression anxiety medication just watch
do this and I just wanted to say thank
you for your patience I would have up
across considerations do
we're not using it foring right now and
I don't think we need to um because we
have we have like Transformations after
that you know takes this Json data and
it will transform into different
features so I don't think we'll be doing
that just
yet I was curious about the structure of
the responses like is it La specific
that it tends to try to respond in more
human read lists and then you have to
perform rejects or can you just try to
force it to respond in a CH
off I tried to force it into a Json is
still it wasn't as consistent I know
like that is one way to do it as
well yeah that is another way to do
it
yeah
um we didn't because we have to use an
open source like we can't send data
outside of our environment um and just
for sake I didn't get to it but this is
our infrastructure is L 2 7 with bit
quantization um employment was used on
tation inference um on two
a100 the the inference speed was. four 4
to six seconds per call uh so
yeah that is for sure a concern and a fe
that I have night years about um I think
this prompt is generalized enough that
it's if it's really really specific that
if it has if
it's performing any as well like H
having any form of performance it should
do as task because it's so
small the numbers I won't trust it but
for the yes orale for the at least the
first pass in the disease classification
that one is pretty quite trustworthy and
also for the for the canot answers like
for the end so I guess you can at least
you can you know what you cannot answer
you know to get like a question coverage
or something um or at least
number yeah since you do have some
labels you try
out
yeah fine tuning I believe is only for
structure output because there's by find
to like I'm thinking I don't actually
wanted to retain applicant information
so I just wanted to know okay output
numbers or output Json you know output
this is the format in which I want you
to output and it's currently doing that
without F tuning so I can can try to
like train aapter or something and add
it on I think that would be very
interesting but I just didn't
need yeah so in the
confusing how many
many or something iot um so like yeah in
my experience um llms were like don't
get distracted by wording that we don't
that as hum don't like focus
on
so first use a first like use the first
passive n to extract the years and then
answer the questions the thing that's
been
count that's an interesting
thought
I think we'll have to take that see
exactly map out like draw the white
board what
you no I think it's a multi-step process
like it doesn't work directly we
can did youer any TR what were I
answer the answers would
missing um then it wouldn't answer let's
say emergency room not like majority of
people wouldn't have you to the
emergency room so that question was
always cannot
answer stop medication is
another have you had certain tests done
was one so yeah but missing just missing
information what be cannot
answer she was like yes or no and it was
just left cannot answer yeah
cannot answer or sometimes it wouldn't
say anything which case you pass it
again so they said have you ever
why have you ever been hospitalized was
I have a do fluffy what would the L the
LM say yes
no the applicant said I have not had
coffee I have a
do fluffy H that that wouldn't answer
the question wouldn't
ites it it would not
extract that would not answer the
question it would say not
answer yeah there's no find I didn't
fine tune because fine I believe fine
tune is only for structure and we I
didn't need it to retain applicant info
so the the underwrite is not fine is not
involved in this process really um but
we're using their previous decision to
use for eval evaluations to get that
number because they labeled stuff before
so now I iterate
that
what does that mean
expand just curious is more of
a yeah so our whole department I guess
is called integrated analytics and our
mission is to automate the underwriter
with these ml models so a traditional
way of underwriting would be the you
know person looks at your application
takes into all the factors looks at our
underwriting manual and decides person
RIS and now it's done with many many
models stacked together um to look at
your medical history to look look at
your um drug history and and make a
decision on each of those factors and we
stack those numbers together so that is
being done but after this process so the
the friction point was converting that
that information into our feature
engineering um like this pipeline um so
yeah that part is already done but the
information to travel to that pipeline
uh is is still
manual
thank you so much M for all the
information and presentation thank you
so
[Applause]
much